nba superstar and social activist
carmelo anthony is launching a new
initiative
aimed at highlighting black fashion
designers through his fashion label it's
called stay mellow
anthony a 10-time all-star who is a
long-time champion for social justice
is also known for his style we could say
off the court
his new fashion initiative look at a
myth called the propel program
it aims to support black designers with
the debut collection
unveiled last night in a virtual show
for new york fashion week which is
underway this week
anthony told us he hopes this new
program will give underrepresented
designers a platform
for years to come we as black people are
cultured we create the culture
how do we think about what's going to
happen to us in
a black community in five years from a
creative standpoint what does that look
like
that's the question nba star carmelo
anthony is trying to answer
[Music]
with a new clothing collection he's
calling a black future
it's part of the propel program a new
initiative anthony is launching to
support the black creative community
and he's calling on seven emerging
designers to make that vision
a reality what was your mission what was
your goal i didn't know what it was at
first
and then now it's like we deal with so
much trauma
daily like all day all night there's
always a black and brown community who's
been affected by that so how do we give
the
people that's dealing with this trauma
or need to outlet or need resources
to propel them forward yeah and it
doesn't sound to me either that this is
a one and done for you
no this is a black future is one of the
best things that i've done you know to
sit there with those
designers you know on on the zoom calls
i want to thank everybody because
what i'm trying to create here hasn't
been done yet and it wasn't just about
designing
like we have real conversations just
about life
because a lot of those designers are
actually still in
those communities that's being affected
how are you feeling as
we sit here in the state that we're in
you know there was another incident in
the news
involving a black man and a police
officer also in the news two police
officers
shot how are you navigating all of this
processing
it's it's hard it's hard to to wake up
and hear
about another tragedy police killing or
somebody killing the police right it's
just that's just where we at
as a as a country right now and for the
black
community we're tired of it we just fed
up with it so
on the flip side of that to see the two
cops who got shot we don't want that
either like we don't
we don't need that you wrote a very
moving letter in july
addressed to young men and women of
color
and you said it's hard for me to tell
you not to be afraid when i'm
afraid what did you mean i'm afraid of
the unknown
i don't know how to keep having these
conversations with
the younger generation my son i never
thought i would have to have this
conversation with him
at 13. i'm fearful of like telling him
the wrong thing or or my emotions coming
you know being put on the forefront
because he's going to take everything i
say
and how i say it and he's going to he's
going to build off of that
it is the conversation no black parent
wants to have with their child
but despite the fear anthony is setting
an example for his son kion
by using his voice to speak for change
you know what
enough is enough so you were recently
guest editor-in-chief of slam magazine
yeah it was very powerful what was your
message in the magazine
the overall message was look the time is
now right like
my son is on his cover this is this
these are the new voices
the most important voices this is the
future our time is now to make a change
i'm sure it was a deliberate choice
where you're both in hoodies yes just
because i have a hoodie
don't make me a gangster don't make me a
thug don't make me this don't make me
that
i am who i am at the end of the day so
my son have it he's definitely not you
know
not intimidated anybody and i'm not
intimidating anybody
anthony is no stranger to speaking his
mind and opening his heart
earlier this year he spoke candidly
about the challenges he faced
after parting ways with the houston
rockets in 2018.
at the time he went unsigned for a year
before eventually joining the portland
trailblazers
on the uninterrupted podcast you talked
very frankly where you said
you hit rock bottom and that you got
through with the help of kobe and lebron
what what did you mean like it was just
like oh this is happening
you know i never thought this could
happen to me like i was just so naive
about it
you know so uh you know kobe was there
for me you know when i was talking to
him lebron was there at times
um it was just certain people that would
just give me little nuggets
here and there and it came from people
you respected and it came from people
it came from people i respected but also
it came for people i didn't even know
too now you're in portland
and when you went to portland did you
think that portland would be the place
for you
because you're kicking butt in portland
i didn't i didn't think that i didn't
know what
what to think uh by the time i got to
portland
i could just tell you i had worked so
hard mentally
emotionally spiritually to get to the
point where i was
able to accept it yeah so for so long i
had disconnected myself
from the game because i just felt like
all right the game doesn't love me the
way that i love the game anymore
so maybe it's time for me to walk away
and that's where i was at
so when i got the call from pauline it's
like i already knew what i wanted
i was at peace with it you know are we
going to be able to work together
are we going to do this together do you
need me or do you want me
like it's a was that an important
distinction that was the point that was
a very important decision
or do you want me what's more important
want
want why because if you want me then you
would do
everything that you have to do to make
it work yeah right
if you need me you can uh yeah i need
you but uh you know we can look over
here too right yeah
so i was very big on them saying look we
want you here
you know we believe in you uh are you
happy there
i'm happy i get the impression mello
that black excellence are not just words
to
you no black excellence is a movement
it's it's it's who we are it's what we
have inside of us we've always had
black excellence but now we have our
voice we have a platform
and i'm going to continue bringing
people along with me amazing
carmelo anthony very smart very
thoughtful he he thinks
a lot about what's happening in the
country and he said you know i'm not a
politician
he goes i'm not even really into
politics what i'm into is my community
so it's not to me about democrat or
republican it's about right and wrong
and i'm looking for someone who does
right
you remind me of mary morris in that
respect you know it's not about you know
democrat republican it's about right and
wrong and standing in the right place
and
he feels very strongly about young
people i love this part where he says
there are three words i tell them
love hell and write what does that mean
when you love something
you will go through hell for it to make
it right and so it's
love hell and right and you love
something you go through hell i love
what he said there right at the end that
he's going to bring
he intends to bring people along with
him which is which is a real act of
generosity i'm used to the carmel the
post game carmelo when he played with
the knicks because i'm a knicks fan
yeah i i don't know this carmella that
well i was saying the same thing and i
really like him
well speaking about the nick says
there's rumors that you know people want
him to come back to the knicks that
knicks were talking i asked him about
that and he goes i'm in
portland i'm very happy in portland he
wouldn't even go there on that but a lot
of people would be happy to see him come
back to new york
yeah well i'm glad he's happy that's the
main thing you know his wife is lala
anthony and their son kai and they live
in new york that's another reason so
they're commuting back that is tough the
coast-to-coast thing is
they're making it work they're making it
work